what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpour back at it again to
discuss a very special chapter one punch
man where saitama takes on garo and we
see what these two are capable of and
it's nuts so make sure to stay tuned for
this one if you do enjoy these one punch
man videos you want to keep them coming
you know what to do chill cite them
within and one punch that like button
remember smashing is sight to my energy
and passing is fear ugly energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos lastly while you
wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my growing one punch
man playlist that includes videos on all
s-class heroes all dragon and god level
threats all a-class heroes and we got
another s-class video coming out soon so
be on the lookout for that and a lot
more videos link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
cover photos great this time around with
us being asked is that person menengaro
a devil or a god we see garo's body but
it's set up in such a way that it looks
like a demonic face if you look at it in
a different way absolutely love it the
chapter is called tougher than a
mountain and since we are covering a
fight between saitama and garo it's hard
to say which one this will be referring
to but my guess would be saitama even
though garu bounces back a lot as well
garo has to regenerate sometimes while
saitama usually just stays unfazed
making him the tougher of the two if you
will garo is upset from the beginning he
can tell monsterization is speeding up
and he is a lot stronger than before and
yet it doesn't feel like he's catching
up to saitama at all saitama is less
focused on the fight and more interested
in garo's motivations asking him what
exactly he wants to accomplish i love
how saitama messes with garo's
self-image again and again garo wants to
be seen as a monster despite being a
pretty good guy deep down and saitama
keeps undermining that monster image he
asks if garo really does have a grudge
against heroes why is he working with
them he tells him to just straight up be
a hero instead of pretending to be a
monster while doing heroic stuff it's
funny because you know saitama is just
trying to be honest but it comes off as
so patronizing that garo can only insult
him back garo says he only worked with
metal bat for efficiency reasons so he
could reach his goal saitama says oh
yeah absolute evil and world peace or
something
and garo is sweating wondering where he
got the world peace thing from saitama
clearly seems to be on to something
physically and figuratively saitama can
see through garo's tough shell saitama
points out how garo is the kind of guy
to encourage a crying kid to get back on
his feet and try again which is clearly
heroic rather than monster behavior he
says he should team up with that kid
while garo angrily charges him having
heard enough he does seem to be fast
enough to land some shots on saitama but
it's hard to say if that's because he's
fast enough or because saitama lets him
since the attacks don't really hurt
saitama so why wouldn't he take some
garo keeps pounding on saitama even
using named attacks like god slayer
instant attack saitama and this is
hilarious appears from a distance under
a rock showing that while garu is busy
attacking the ground where he thinks
saitama is he's actually just hitting
the ground to no purpose satima throws a
rock at him and even accidentally
insults his martial arts which remember
garu is very proud about he thinks he's
reached the pinnacle of martial arts and
that his is the ultimate martial art
saitama just says that weird way you're
moving and making punches miss is that
martial arts or something it's too funny
how saitama accidentally knows how to
push all of garo's buttons garo destroys
the rock thrown at him and reaffirms
that he has the ultimate martial arts
technique he says saitama should be
grateful and relish the experience even
as saitama starts effortlessly dodging
the punches angar was upset by how
saitama's outpacing his combo attacks
with his reflexes and reaction speed
alone this is an ongoing theme in the
battle martial arts trained to
perfection versus no martial arts on
saitama's part and how saitama keeps
coming out on top despite how
pretentious garo tries to be about the
importance of his martial art even now
he thinks to himself that saitama's
technique is that of a complete amateur
and that there's plenty of openings to
take advantage of he says saitama will
lose because he has no technique and as
a result garo can read all of his moves
he lands a significant godslayer combo
and sends arcade baldy flying saitama's
body destroys a building and garo
destroys it further with a kind of
energy blast called great power attack
bonus points for creative naming you
can't deny that when it comes to how he
names his attacks garo can be very
childish the buildings turn to ash
showing garo's power garo says no matter
how tough saitama's bones and flesh are
there's no way to train internal organs
and his insides should be torn to shreds
by now but saitama just shows up looking
fine as usual to garo's shock
accidentally garo also saved some people
who were stuck under the building and
saitama lets them know it was garo's
work as well they then thanked the
demonic looking garo in a hilarious
scene upsetting garo because it's
ruining his ultimate evil image that
he's trying to convey then we get this
awkward moment of the two just standing
there and saitama drops one of my
favorite lines of the chapter saying man
absolute evil sure is good at saving
people and angered garo loses it and
goes hard trying to land a hit on
saitama as he dodges with a smile on his
face then there's a volcano threatening
people in their homes garo continues to
evolve growing demonic wings too and
saitama in his usual patronizing way
smiles and encourages garo by saying you
got a little better again garo says you
call this a little better as he sends
saitama flying to the volcano saitama
was hit into the volcano so hard he's
buried into the mountain surrounded by
rubble it almost looks like when yamcha
was in the crater after the cyberman got
him garo doesn't give up and murata is
doing a great job of making him look
cool and demonic at the same time he
hits a laying saitama with all he's got
causing the volcano to shatter and
leading the lava down the other side of
the mountain so that the people are
saved again garu has accidentally saved
people while looking more demonic than
ever and this really goes with the is he
a devil or a god question on the cover
page because he clearly looks like a
monster but he's saving people again and
again albeit seemingly accidentally in
this chapter he's pushed himself a lot
and he finally takes the chance to pant
and get a breather after all in his mind
there's no way saitama could survive a
hit that destroyed a mountain right but
then as most of us expected saitama
suddenly delivers a punch that sends
garo flying back himself garo can't
believe he's unaffected after all that
this is where he realizes that saitama
is quite literally sturdier than a
mountain aka tougher than a mountain we
also see an epic silhouette of saitama
here as well with lava spewing behind
him truly epic stuff i must say the
illustration this chapter have been
amazing saitama is not only fine he
laughs amused at the whole shtick where
garo is not even trying and things work
out perfectly saitama says garo kind of
reminds him of king since he has great
hero instincts as well and that is the
end of this epic and hilarious chapter
who's your mvp what do you expect to
happen next do you think garo is or will
become the strongest monster we've seen
as he continues to evolve this to me is
what one punch man is all about and i'm
hoping garo continues to land cool hits
on saitama that even if they don't upset
saitama still arguably position garo in
a higher category than other monsters
who have failed to accomplish the same
things against saitama if you did enjoy
this review and want to keep them coming
smash that like button with a serious
punch remember smashing that like button
is saitama energy and passing is fear or
ugly energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos remember
another s-class video is coming out very
soon lastly while you wait for the next
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one punch man playlist that
includes videos on all s-class heroes
all dragon and god level monsters and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys